그래서 여러분들이 또 아셔야 될게
강남구가 다 잘 팔리진
않고네 안녕하세요 이번에 상반기
거래량 데이터가 나와 가지고
여러분들한테 정리해서 알려 드리면
좋을 거 같아서 영상을 좀 켜게
됐습니다 올해 7월까지 거래가 신고된
거 기준으로 상업용 부동산 기준으로
제가 좀 통계자료 만들었는데 한번 좀
같이 보면서 좀 보도록 하겠습니다
작년보다는 거래량이 확실히 좀 많이
늘어났고요 1분기보다 2분기 거래량이
월등이 되게 높 높아졌습니다 2분기가
확실히 좀 거래량이 많이 늘어났고
그리고 작년과 비교해서는 거의 한 두
배 정도 어 거래량이 좀 더
늘어났습니다 상반기에 최고에 좀
거래가 많이 된 시기는 3월 달에
거래량이 좀 많이 늘어났고 금액대를
보면은 50억 미만이 전체 한 67%
정도 됩니다 그래서 저희가 꼬마
빌딩이라고 얘기하는 규모가 거의
대부분을 좀 차지했다고 보시면 될 거
같고 그리고 중공 년도를 보니까
20년 이상 된 건물이 전체에 한
65% 정도 됩니다 시장에 좀 낡은
건물 오래된 건물들이 거래가 많이
됐다라고 좀 보시면 될 거 같고
이것뿐만 아니라 지금 서울시에 좀
오래된 건물들이 워낙 많아요 그래서
대체적으로 다 그때 통계자료 봤을
때는 한 거의 한 50% 정도는 다
노후화된 건물이라고 합니다 그것
때문에 아직까지 좀 이렇게 오래된
건물들이 좀 많이 있다라고 보시면 될
거 같고 서울시 전체에서 강남구
거래량이 좀 월등이 많아요 그래서
저희 회사도 그렇지만 대부분 강남구
위주로 좀 거래가 많이 됐습니다
강남구가 거래가 제일 많고 그다음에
종로구 중구 마포구 서초구 성동구
이런 순으로 좀 거래가 많았고 저는
빌딩 투자할 때 가장 중요한게
환금성이 생각하거든요 그니까 빌딩은
환금성이 매우 낮아요 그니까 잘 안
팔립니다 그것 때문에 제가 계속
말씀드리지만 빌딩 투자한다고 하면은
환금성이 좋은데 투자를 하셔야 돼요
근데 많은 분들이 어떻게해요 대부분
다 자기 고향에 사고 싶어 합니다
수익률은 낮은 문제고 어찌됐든 잘
팔리는는데 사야 됩니다 그래서 잘
팔리는 데가 가격이 오르는 데고
매수자가 되게 많은 곳이에요 그리고
강남구 내에서 잘 팔리는 동이 있어요
그래서 강남구 내에서 거래가 잘되는
동이 농현동 신사동 뭐 역삼동 대치동
삼성동 청담동 근데 개포동이 원동
같은 경우에는 거래량이 그 많지
않습니다 그래서 여러분들이 또 아셔야
될게 강남구가 다 잘 팔리진 않고이
중에 잘 팔리는 동이 있고 안 팔리는
동이 있구나 어 여러분들이 좀 이런
부분도 아셔야 됩니다 그리고 그 해당
동에 잘 팔리는 금액대가 있어요
30억 미만 같은 경우에는 서울시 좀
외곽에 몰려 있고 70억 이상 되는
경우에는 신사 노년 역삼 대치 서초
청담 그래서 이거 같이 좀 주요
지역에 많이 몰려 있습니다 서울시
외곽 지역 같은 경우에는 수익률이 몇
프로든간에 금액이 커지면 안 팔립니다
여러분들이 반대로 생각해 보면 돼요
내가 만약에 뭐 70억 이상의 건물을
사는데 서울시 외곽에 있는 건물은
많이 안 사려고 하거든요 여러분들이
빌딩 살 때 파는 거를 반드시 생각을
해보셔야 됩니다 반드시이를 계속 몇
번 얘기하는지 모르겠는데 그리고 이제
서초구는 서초동의 거래가 많고 그다음
마포구는 석교동 홍대 인근이
서교동이삿짐센터 보고 많이 투자를
하거든요 빌딩 투자의 꽃은 시세
차이이기 때문에 잘 팔리는 곳 잘
팔리는 동네 잘 팔리는 동네 어느
정도 금액대가 거래가 잘 되는지
여러분들 유심히 보실 필요가
있습니다이 상반기 데이터는 여러분들이
보시기에 너무 좀 유익한 정보라고
생각이 들고 제가 영상에 링크를 좀
걸어 놓을테니까 여기 링크에 들어오셔
가지고 자세하게 보셨으면 좋겠습니다
그래 좀 전체적으로 정리를 해보자면
일단 거래량이 많이 늘어났다 2분기
부터 좀 거래량이 좀 많이 늘어났고
그리고 거래가 되는 데는 금액대가
낮은 건물들이 주로 거래가 됐고
오래된 건물이 거래가 많이 됐다 좀
잘 팔리는데만 거래가 됐다 그래서
강남구 거래량이 좀 많이 월등이
거래가 됐고 강남구 내에서도 잘
팔리는 동네가 있다 렇게 좀 보시면
될 거 같습니다 금액이 커질수록 주요
지역에 투자를 해야 되고 보면 제가
항상 하는 얘기인 거 같아요 주요
지역에 살아 팔리는 곳에 살아 그리고
환금성이 제일 중요하다 뭐 이런
얘기를 항상 하는데 그거와 맞게
이렇게 좀 거래가 계속 됐습니다네
그래서 오늘 영상 여기까지 하고요 또
이런 데이터들 여러분들한테 또 알려
드릴 만한 정보가 있으면 영상을 켜
가지고 정보들을 좀 전달해 드리도록
하겠습니다 늘 영상 여기까지
하겠습니다
[음악]
감사합니다 e